[Music]
what do you want
what are you talking about i'm busy
right now can i call you back
you call me what what i gotta call you
back man i'm working right now tnt i'll
talk to you later bye
all right i'll [ __ ] you [ __ ] bye
[Music]
i'm working what do you want bro you can
oh man you call me what
why are you calling me at work man i'm
working right now oh i called you
what of course you just called me you
don't know you called me i thought you
just called me
what you calling me for
i'm sitting right i'm sitting right next
to here what you're calling me for
cause i don't know whatever man goodbye
[Music]
yes hey i'm busy right now can i call
you back
yeah yes you called me man and i'm not
busy
what's up hey i'm busy right now can i
call you back
okay you got me
i'm on this zoom car man what you doing
man hey i'm busy right now can i call
you back
what up man i'm busy right now can i
call you back
man get out of here man call me back
whatever you want to call me back man
yo i'm busy right now can i call you
back
what i'm busy right now can i call you
back keep playing
yes hey i'm busy right now can i call
you back
is this like y'all having a contest
who's the who can get the most famous
guy on the phone right away
uh i'm just busy can i call you back
yeah sure
sure sure kitty call me back oh i'm busy
right now can i call you back
you mother
wait you got chris rock's phone number
tick-tock challenge
oh my god that was that you were just
this was a vehicle for kenny to show his
contacts oh
so it was so funny because i'm saying i
was
you know at first i was like i had the
list of the kids and i was like
uh chris rocco hit me he always hits me
doing the game but always have these
comments
so i was like you know what let me do
this and then it just rolled down i was
like let me do the famous list
oh man shout out to my man dion dude
he's got the new movie wait
dion's got just got my man dion i got to
shout him out on this because he just
signed today the new movie to do
on john lewis oh really who's going to
play john lewis
he hasn't just got that he's going to
direct it so he's right in the middle of
a zoom call probably talking about that
exact same thing
and you interrupted it you know that's
one of those things like
if you get to play that role yes yeah
it's special
it's special